alistair bunkel alastair what's
happening
well there are three sources of state
electricity or there have been i should
say three sources of state electricity
in lebanon you've got two floating power
barges that are sponsored by the turkish
government but the contract for them ran
out last week so
they haven't been able to supply any
electricity and then you've got a power
station in the north of the country and
a power station in the south of the
country and both of those have run out
of enough fuel to keep generating power
thereby meaning that there is no uh
provision of state electricity at the
moment in lebanon
so
people are now resorting to personal
private generators uh that has its own
problems as well because
fuel is short and hard to get hold of
and fuel is incredibly expensive and so
whereas people were receiving two or
three hours of state electricity a day
up until now and then supplementing that
with their own personal generators now
there is no state electricity and the
people will be affected the worst as is
always the case will be the very poorest
those who cannot get any fuel or afford
a generator i mean you know there are
small mercies it is not the height of
the summer so things like the necessity
for air conditioning is not quite as
much but the longer this goes on for the
more profound the effects will be it's
not the first time it's happened it
happened a couple of months ago the
government sorted out pretty swiftly
they are saying that they'll need about
48 hours to sort this problem out we'll
see but as i say i think the longer it
goes on for the more the patients will
run out on the streets
um allison give us the context for all
of this because it didn't obviously
happen overnight and there are many that
would argue lebanon is the country on
the verge of complete and utter meltdown
well i would say that lebanon is a
collapsed state uh
in almost every sense except
for whatever reason it hasn't yet quite
collapsed into any sort of civil war
despite the problems they've been going
through uh for the last year and a bit
it all well it didn't start with the
beirut port explosion the the corruption
within the government was endemic before
that but the bay report explosion uh
ripped the heart out of the capital and
really sort of precipitated this spiral
downwards inflation is so rampant in
lebanon that it has been compared by the
world bank to that of weimar germany and
zimbabwe you know we are talking that
kind of level of inflation so even
middle class uh previously wealthy
lebanese are now finding themselves uh
finding life very very difficult as well
they are often then leaving lebanon to
go elsewhere and
access to
really basic staff food basic medicine
when i was there a couple of months ago
we met people who just couldn't even get
paracetamol off the shelves of
pharmacies and then you've got
long long queues of
of cars and vehicles waiting at the
petrol stations
in and around lebanon to try and fill up
uh with with precious reserves of fuel
and
you know you've got this situation where
the country is utterly deteriorating at
the moment as i say the security
situation has remained reasonably stable
but you think that it won't take much to
push it over the brink